[Applause]
katie holmes
seems totally smitten i'm so happy the
41 year old actress was snapped out and
about
enjoying some time with a mystery man at
a restaurant in new york city on tuesday
now e.t can confirm said mystery man is
emilio vitolo and while we don't know
exactly how long they've known each
other
we do know that back in july he
commented on a pic she posted from the
set of the secret dare to dream
adding two dancing girl emojis so just
who is this man who has katie grinning
ear to ear
well we know emilio is 33 years old he's
italian on his dad's side and peruvian
on his mom's side
and he's a chef at emilio's bellato in
soho
his dad emilio vitolo senior bought the
establishment in the early 90s
we also know he's super dedicated to his
job
earlier this year emilio told instyle
magazine quote
if you're going to do a restaurant the
right way you always have to be there
and get this he's even done a little
acting
appearing in inside amy schumer and
royal pains
emilio also has a ton of celeb friends
like whoopi goldberg
joe jonas and the cast of it's always
sunny in philadelphia
and cue the oz because he's a dog dad to
a rottweiler pup named
lil frankie who naturally has
his own instagram as for katie she split
from jamie foxx in
august 2019 and is known for keeping her
private life
hella private but when et caught up with
the actress in july
she did reveal how she had been spending
quarantine with her 14 year old daughter
suri
whom she shares with her ex tom cruise
this lap town has had a lot of silver
linings
and we've all you know i've
really enjoyed having even though i
wasn't seeing my friends in person but
taking
time to facetime and really
be there um be present and
i think when you have less you you're
more creative and i think that
this year has also been a reminder of
like the simple things
are really beautiful and that is
those are the gifts of life